hey constantly people ask me what is
your favorite game
and i always reply
honey pop
and i find it kind of funny i find it
kind of sad it really offends me when
people say my girlfriend is marzia cause
my girlfriend is obviously
tiffany hi there
are you talking to me yeah you oh
[Music]
i
i think i'm in love
okay
maybe we can take a step back here
my name is q nice to meet you
i literally can't remember anything
right now
right
man this is your lucky day buddy
no she's just going she's just leaving
i miss her so much hey you rise and
shine we've got work to do
so sorry uh just
uh i'm up am i gonna have to pull the
covers off
wait a minute
who are you
don't you recognize this adorable face
it's cute
this is the best game
of old damn
okay where are we now
oh my god it's candy crush i'll try to
make this quick some brilliant mind out
there was like
hey kaley crush it's a pretty good game
but wouldn't it be better if we added
anime boobs god damn genius hey
undertale it's a pretty good game
but wouldn't it be better
with animations
[Music]
if only life was this easy all you had
to do was
play candy crush and you get [ __ ]
you know this game really is a dream
coming true i think for all of us and i
think i speak for the entirety of
mankind when i say that it's such a good
game
i'll never get tired of it
almost there almost at the climax baby
here we go
success
that's what it says in real life as well
yes
we did it see i knew you had it in you
all right so where should we go first to
hit up those sexy ladies bro leave a
comment down right now and i will pick
whatever comment that gets the most
fitness club let's go to fitness
[Music]
don't you don't judge my girl tiffany
shut the [ __ ] up okay come on all right
[Laughter]
okay
hey don't take this the wrong way but i
just thought you were cute and i had to
say hi
to
me
[Music]
you're crazy stop it no you stop it all
right no don't worry about it this is
how you do it this is how you do it my
name is tiffany by the way
it's nice to meet you oh that pleasure
you don't seem like a cool guy
on the couch i'll see you around i'm
really cool i'm real cool let's uh let's
talk to her question time have you ever
done any drugs
okay so she's a pure girl
uh never touched it oh really never mind
what what was the right answer to that
[ __ ] we can't [ __ ] up anymore
uh anyway what's your breast size
how old are you me
i'm 20 years old mm-hmm
okay uh let's talk to her one more time
i wonder if you'll remember this
how old am i you literally just you
literally just
hi my name is tiffany
quiz time what is my name
at 20 years oh you remembered i know you
know i pay attention to details i care
about women i said i am not a missouri
genetics all i can think about is food
oh [ __ ] hungry i forgot you have to
like buy them food and [ __ ] all right so
purchase gift all right so
we should buy tennis balls no uh she's
hungry okay food would you like a
wedding cake do you like a sundae
sorry i got a pass why would you like a
fruit i'm not really into that
[ __ ] have a chewing gum
[Music]
yes but i can't help myself
she can't help herself
we are going on a date we are going on a
date hell yeah hell yeah we're going
deep we're gonna dig we're gonna dig
with tiffany we're gonna date oh
[Music]
okay here we go
yeah you like that girl
hell you
[Applause]
[Music]
that's how you do it bros that's how you
get a lady would you like an orange
no thanks
[ __ ] all right we're just gonna
have to spend all our money on tiffany
she's our main [ __ ] and that's what
we're going for you gotta single in
we're going all in on this girl
would you like a tissue
nope hey girl would you like a muffin
so good
so good how tall are you i wish i was
taller
i'm only five foot four five foot four
five foot four remember this remember
this okay all right some candy i'm so
bad i know i have a sweet tooth would
you want some pancakes
oh my god she missed breakfast she loves
pancakes everyone
okay she wants a lemon drop
would you like a lemon drop that's not
weird for anyone to give hey
here's a
lemon drop it's your
favorite drink
would you like would you like a lemon
drop
at school
i made it for you tiffany
[Music]
uh
that's okay oh
okay then when's your
december 2 birthday 22nd december 22nd
december 22nd december 22nd remember
remember
what's your last name
my last name
tiffany tiffany how tall did i say i am
[ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] please please i don't
wow you got it yeah most guys would have
forgotten most guys
not me
ha
what was your first kiss like
i wasted my first kiss on my what the
[ __ ] does that mean the market
what a neat idea our second date i see
don't [ __ ] this up felix
the passion level is maxed out
come on come on this could be it
[Music]
this game don't understand me stupid
game stupid girls i hate girls they're
the dumbest dumb girls
if you're a girl unsubscribe now
now i am a real
misogynattix so you better watch out
[Music]
anyway check out another video uh
similar to this one let me know if you
want me to do another part of this i
would love to play more leave a like if
you enjoyed and as always
stay awesome bros hey but bros only
brofist